The idea of being a man has a change so
dramatically.
Right.
Um,
but particularly I think not just the
responsibilities of a being a father,
which is always been,
you know,
not to get all Kahleel Goubran.
Like these children are on loan to us
and we're supposed to make sure that we
take care of them and,
and we're the stewards of these human
beings,
male roles,
which is something I do,
you know,
my wife and I have written about in the
show because the concept of a father
today is dramatically different.
I mean,
obviously it's different in every family
culture,
but it's different from a generation
ago.
And the idea of what a father's
responsibility,
whether it's coparenting,
whether it's a stay at home dad or just
someone that does lip service to the
idea of sharing responsibility is so
different from 1910 and you know,
like the,
you know,
I have this joke where it's like,
and then you go back to caveman and
they're literally eating their children.
I think it's,
it's perspective on how we treat women,
right?
That is the beginning and the ending of
it.
We are animals.
I start from that premise and we choose
to not behave like animals.
And that's,
you know,
a pretty guiding force through humanity,
whether it,
it gets completely out of control or
just panting like a dog when a,
uh,
an attractive woman walks by.
You know,
I even look at like pornography and all
this stuff where it's,
yeah.
You know,
it's like,
look,
I love naked women.
I really do.
But I also know that I'm a visual human
being and,
and I can't,
uh,
you know,
I can't consume images of naked women
and not have that influence how I view
other women.
I mean,
that's my personal opinion.
I don't,
so like it's like my sexual desires are,
are very valid and real.
But if I,
if I,
uh,
you know,
followed through on every sexual desire,
first of all,
I'd have a thousand children.
No,
but I think then that's not how you,
that's not how you get,
um,
I wouldn't feel very good.
Do you?
I mean,
when I look at my young sons,
I think that,
look,
I know that we love and like the
normalization of porn.
And I'm not,
uh,
you know,
it's like t each their own,
right?
But I don't think that I want my sons
consuming pornography.
I would want my sons to look at an
advertisement and say that is a
beautiful woman,
but she's being objectified.
And I do want even beyond that,
I personally think that,
uh,
in the United States we give credit and
appreciate attractive people too much.
And so I think that I want to instill
that.
I mean,
I think a lot of parents desperately
want to have nerdy children.
So,
but I dunno,
I want my kids to be a,
my sons to be better men than me.
But I think also,
you know,
it's different paths to getting there.
I mean,
look,
I'm Catholic.
You're gonna think I'm crazy.
But I think that's an important tool
also.
But I also think that,
you know,
understanding the logic and science
behind it is vital.
But culturally,
it's interesting.
I saw a clip of match game,
which was a show,
a game show when I was growing up from
the mid seventies eighties I don't know.
And the beginning of the show,
it was just filled with the host more or
less sexually harassing the female
contestants and it was not malicious and
that man did not know he was doing it.
And maybe those women didn't feel icky.
But from our standards today,
it was ridiculous.
I mean,
I also feel like to discredit everything
I've said,
I also think that I don't want us to get
to the point where there isn't passion.
Right.
You know,
when I met my wife and we went on our
first date,
you know,
I aggressively kissed,
or not in a monstrous way,
but even hearing myself describe it,
I don't know if we could do that today
and I'm sure I could have,
because there's,
there's a communication that's unspoken,
right?
When you're courting someone but
courting like it's the 18 hundreds like
you're riding a horse to meet them.
But there is something about,
there's rules,
but there's also,
what's so great about relationships is
that tingling feeling when the chemistry
that we can't articulate works.
Mm.